we have uh some things in common i was
thinking about this uh during the
commercial break when we were talking
about it we both have written for saturn
out live yes i did a long long time ago
when it was a comic strip in the papers
then it evolved into a radio show and
then became a television show uh but um
i was curious it feels to me over the
years like nothing changes right the
host shows up on monday and in my day
total bs we didn't know what we were
going to do yet so would say i would
always say it's you at a zeppelin
factory and people go like could be good
i never wrote that sketch because it was
it was just a placeholder for monday to
get me through monday night right right
everyone did that and then throughout
the week did you ever write a sketch
that you were convinced was going to be
huge like this is going to be great and
then it just didn't go
yeah
yeah i mean
there's a bunch one that comes to mind
that i kept trying to pound in there and
just never happened was um
a character whose name i don't even
remember but he had a catchphrase where
he kept
asking everyone if they wanted to come
with him to the bathroom at a party
which which was born of me actually not
wanting to make the long walk to the
bathroom on the 17th floor
which is uh really far away from the
writers offices it's like quite a walk
it's a long walk and also i'm
notoriously i get lonely really fast
yeah
so it started out as an in the office
bit where i'd be like yeah hey i'm gonna
hit the head you want to come with
i'm gonna hit the head you want to come
with uh-huh you want to come with and
everyone's like no one wants to go with
you to the bathroom
and we were like do you want to come
with to the bathroom
this character yeah
so we wrote it up and it did okay and
then did better the second time at the
table and that actually went to dress
one time dress rehearsal yeah yeah and
yeah exactly dress rehearsal and uh
played pretty bad right
audience just stared at it yeah it was a
lot of it was basically what you just
said was their thought like who says
want to come with to the bathroom
like all 300 people in the audience said
that at the same time who wants it
there's a great thing an audience will
tell you you get enough people in a room
they will give you that they will give
you the correct answer yeah you put and
you try and try and you put something
out there for them you go ah what do you
think of this and when that when all of
them are quiet it means they're not
wrong you're wrong that's true i still
think it's kind of funny though
like
he doesn't matter what you say he's
gonna ask you know okay i guess say
anything i'm gonna try it right now
anything topical uh okay uh hey who do
you think the new pope's gonna be i'm
gonna hit the head you wanna come
with fantastic that was really nice of
you guys thank you
that was like make a wish
what a waste what a waste of a wish
all he wants is to get fake
laugh for her now i can get on the boat
with frodo
drift off to the netherworld